of all when you see f of X or G of X
this is really just saying that that's
the y-value that's the output so if you
want anything just think of this as Y
you can and this is really like y equals
1/2 X plus 2 and y equals negative 2x
plus 3 but they put these domain
restrictions over here next to them and
that just tells you that we only want to
be on this part of the graph when X is
less than 0 and then we want to be on
this part of the graph or this piece you
could think of the graph since it's a
piecewise function when X is greater
than or equal to 0 so let me show you a
couple different ways to approach this
problem one is let's just go ahead and
graph y equals 1/2 X plus 2 so the y
intercept is 2 and the slope is 1/2 so
up 1 over 2 up 1 over 2 or you could go
down 1 left 2 down 1 left 2 like this
and you can go ahead and graph that line
like so ok but then it says only when X
is less than 0 hmm so here's 0 and we're
going less than so to the left so that
means that we don't need this part of
the graph here we don't even need this
point here since it's less than but not
equal to 0 so I'm just gonna put an open
circle there and going to the left okay
with me so far the second part we're
gonna graph y equals negative 2x plus 3
so the y intercept is 3 and the slope is
down 2 over 1 down 2 over 1 so you can
see this line looks like this right now
notice this one says X is greater than
or equal to 0 so it equals 0 see when x
is 0 and greater than meaning to the
right we're gonna be on this part of the
graph this part we don't need okay now
you know I mentioned there was a
different way to do this the other way
to do this is you can make a table right
you can make an XY table for both of
these piecewise functions so for this
one it says X is less than 0 so I'm
gonna pick values that are 0 negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 and I'm going to
plot those points now you might say well
wait a second Mario X is less than 0 not
equal to 0 well you'll still want to put
0 in you're going to get two but at 0 2
instead of filling in that circle like a
solid circle you're gonna make that open
so it's going all the way up to this
point but not including so you want to
use that point even though it's less
than but not equal to but just make sure
you make it open same thing for this one
you can say okay when X is greater than
equal to 0 0 1 2 3 put those values in
get your Y coordinates plot those points
and you can do it that way so let's do
example number 2 here G of X which is
just you know another function ok this
is like saying why we're just calling
this the G function instead of the F
function like the first one and here you
can see we actually have three equations
so here what we're going to do is we're
going to graph y equals x squared minus
one so that means it's a parabola an x
squared graph shift down one and if we
graph this let's see if I can do that
one two three four nice and accurately
here for us okay so they're like this
and like this
so this graph looks like this okay but
see how it says when X is less than
negative two so if I go over here to
negative two and I go up to the graph
less than but not equal to so this is
actually going to be open less than
meaning when we're going to the left so
all of this we don't need I'm going to
go back and I'm gonna erase it okay like
so so it's just on that part of the
graph okay then the second one says y
equals two now we know the line y equals
two is a horizontal line like this but
only when X is in between negative two
and zero so here's negative two right
here one two negative two okay and it's
equal to so that means it includes that
point up to zero and an equals zero so
includes that point so it's just going
to be that piece right there the rest of
this we're going to erase we don't need
it we're just in between X is a negative
2 and X is zero right in here okay and
then the third piece y equals 3x plus
one the y intercept is one right and the
slope is 3 so we're going up 3 over 1 up
3 over 1 and so on so you can see the
graph looks like this now notice it's
greater than but not equal to 0 so this
is actually going to be open or hollow
okay and greater than meaning as we go
to to the right greater than 0 the X
values are greater now this is still a
function because it passes that vertical
line test see even here it's only
crossing once it's crossing here but not
here since that's open same thing here
here
not here